tras la mortal estampida del sábado que
causó más de 150 muertos durante una
celebración de Halloween el alcalde de
seúl osijun Se disculpó por la
negligencia de la policía que no impidió
el desastre si Hulk no pudo evitar el
llanto
nos aseguraremos de tener medidas para
que accidentes tan devastadores nunca
vuelvan a ocurrir
en su discurso o si junta también
recordó entre lágrimas su encuentro con
el familiar de una víctima
visite a una persona que tenía una hija
de 20 años en el centro médico nacional
me dijo que su hija sobreviviría pero
escuché que ella falleció esta mañana me
disculpo por la demora en disculparme
las transcripciones de las 11 llamadas a
los servicios de emergencia revelan la
negligencia de la policía los ciudadanos
advirtieron horas antes sobre un posible
accidente por la multitud concentrada en
el estrecho callejón
ahora en este callejón la gente se
acercó para rendir tributo a Los
fallecidos entre ofrendas y lamentos el
malestar de la ciudadanía con la policía
van aumento
ahora que veo cómo es este callejón
realmente quiero señalar que la policía
podría haber venido a desviar a la
multitud
el presidente de Corea del Sur y un
hielo declaró un periodo de duelo
nacional y designó al distrito de seúl
como una zona de desastre Las
investigaciones siguen en curso para
aclarar las causas de la mortal
estampida